i want to say  the first thing i noticed when i watched  the video was  how amazing the song was but i knew  how important it was for everyone who's  got a sweating problem  to see you with that sweat rag bro hey  look look cook's got his sweat rag right  there  every fat [ __ ] got a sweat rag no  [ __ ] even if you ain't got in your  pocket in your car or something to dab  that forehead stop playing with games  i know you got it oh god how much love  did you get for the sweat rag  a lot no come on by making some [ __ ] no  [ __ ] yo y'all gotta  the lrg and the sweat rag he's going up  and i was using that [ __ ] too yeah he  was he was patting himself  oh god i was sweating like a  [ __ ] it was like a [ __ ] 94  degree out hottest sailboat i was like  look at this guy with the sweat rack  homies fat boy [ __ ] always